hey dear we are friends welcome back and
before we get started with my new video
I gotta give a couple of thank-yous
thank you to all of you for watching my
Mass Effect 3 video about the Mass
Effect 3 ending and showing the love I
really appreciate it you guys rock and
second thank you goes to Michael Bay
thank you Michael Bay for opening your
mouth and having words come out thus
giving me something to do today
cuz we're now gonna talk about what he
said if you guys didn't know Michael Bay
is producing the new Ninja Turtles movie
and he's now come out and said this is
the quote when you see this movie kids
are going to believe one day that these
turtles actually do exist when we are
done with this movie these turtles are
an alien race that's that's the point
nice that one right in the garbage
that's awesome yes it is no longer
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles this
teenage alien Ninja Turtles probably not
going to call it that but that is what
it is
right there's a little thing about me
when people talk I always wonder why did
they say what they said I always just
wonder that so I've got a wonder to
myself why did Michael Bay decide to
make them aliens and not mutants and if
he didn't decide it well he's the one
who told us about it so now he's getting
blamed for it's just the way the world
works I guess I mean really did it not
work before them being Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles is what made them so
successful back in the day so it worked
if it ain't broke don't fix it it's just
kind of a rule of life he's like oh the
meat doesn't too hard to write or let's
just have him crash land on earth now
it's done so is this a planet of all
turtles like fully grown Turtles were
the dominant species on the planet and
on this planet a fully grown humanoid
turtles is splinter from there is it a
planet of Turtles and rats who have
evolved to be in the dominant species on
the planet and they all teach each other
ninjutsu now I'm not saying the whole
mutant story arc is perfect or that it
would happen
you know if Turtles dabbled in immunity
news or something but this feels like
Michael Bay gone alright look that's not
completely logical what is more logical
is that there's going to be a planet out
there of all fully grown Turtles that no
ninjutsu I mean after all I don't think
a high school students gonna be sitting
in class to shoot lasers out of his eyes
and become Cyclops from x-men but it
works for the movie and some people will
probably say Jeremy look you're reading
too much into this man kids won't care
it's gonna be fun for kids well if kids
won't care then just keep them mutants
at least you won't have like a ravenous
mob of people who loved Ninja Turtles
back in the day that hate you now and
Michael Bay has said it is paraphrasing
here he's like the fans need to chill
out look I'm working with
the original makers of the Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles to make this work
what you mean the guys who add a point
thought to themselves that hey having a
female Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle a
fifth turtle actually works and that's a
good idea
yeah apparently that whole inspiration
has now flooded back to them and the
fact that they're now teenage alien
Ninja Turtles that's only like fifty
percent of what concerns me about this
the other 50% is the fact that he went
on to say and they're going to be tough
edgy funny and completely lovable it's
not the tough it's not the edgy it's not
the completely lovable it's the funny
because Michael Bay we've seen your
version of funny it starts out with two
completely annoying parents and the
Transformers movies goes on to be in
John Totoro in the Transformers movies
and then those two transformers I call
Jar Jar Binks because there's that
annoying and yes Ninja Turtles are
supposed to be all of the things that he
described I just don't think he can
write funny that well for Ninja Turtles
best part of this I can go like this be
like now I'm done I don't need this
movie there was a Ninja Turtles movie
that was made in the late 80s and it
worked and it still works now I've seen
it recently I actually reviewed the
movie you can check out my review if you
want to I'm just saying it's a good
family movie it has good themes it's
actually kind of dark even it worked
then it works now we still have that we
don't need the new one so teenage alien
Ninja Turtles have you heard this news
if you haven't well sorry I had to take
the back to your face and you had to
find out here but now you know these it
came from me someone who loves you what
do you think about this comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]